2008 oh 2008 i was in eighth grade
ew i was a young 20 year old
dead dead dead broke i was newly gay
my glory days in the fast pace new york
city
do i remember 2008 the world was good
let's go back to 2008.
[Music]
i think single ladies the song forced
people that weren't ready for marriage
into marriage
single ladies by beyonce i think i
listened to that song for four years
straight
everyone thought they were beyonce
everyone and their mom thought they were
beyonce they put the black little
leotard on
they had the ring and they were like
this became the move for everything
oh my single ladies i'm a single lady me
and my best friend at the time riley
were in
my basement watching single ladies video
on repeat to try to learn the dance
and if you didn't know the dance moves
you better get the hell off the floor
because there were about 20 other gay
guys and girls
that knew every single move
that really is the power of the beyonce
right beyonce you are an icon you stay
an
icon and everything you do is
breathtaking lift for you love you
we'll just ugh these are my crowns
crocs my father's favorite shoe brand oh
god i hate crocs
i think they're stupid i think they are
a waste of a shoe i'm gonna have to
admit that i wore crocs
i there are certain things in life that
i'm just like
somebody just gave up on fashion
somebody just gave up on like the way
that they look i wore them to like my
internship i wore them to school
if you didn't want to be in the in
crowd uh you'd buy some crops i would
have like a nice red dress
and then on my feet were crocs croc is
disgusting i thought it was disgusting
then i kind of think it's disgusting now
if you're not an essential worker
[Music]
jeans boots with the fur yes i remember
flo rida
it took me a long time to actually
realize that flo rider
was like a bougie way to say florida i
didn't know what apple bottom jeans were
i still don't you know apple bottom
figure celebrating
a big nice ass i mean look everybody
wanted the apple bottom jeans i was very
familiar with boots
with the fur because i owned a lot of
uggs
blue ryder is from florida it's like 90
degrees
why would you be wearing boots with the
fur maybe that's one reason why
everybody was looking at her this song
was
you know an anthem for every frat party
i went to
everybody was literally dropping low and
it was not like
it wasn't sexy at all i always feel like
songs that give you directions do well
and like it goes low low low
so everybody had to get low low low low
maybe not
[Music]
myspace everyone was so in love with it
it was like a step
up from friendster don't tell my parents
because i i don't even think they know
this
still till this day but in 2008 i had a
myspace
i did have a myspace but i am a daughter
of patient parents
so i was not allowed to put my profile
picture up i was
but have any photos of myself you can
send people messages
in front of everyone there was no direct
messages everyone
would be all in your business and we
loved it my face was like the beginning
of my digital career like i literally
would like
um take self-portraits which was what we
call them at the time i was so hung up
on getting the right song the right
background
making sure that i was like that girl on
my
face one of my pictures or whatever
picture you put on there it was a quote
from lauren conrad
um that said like boys are like purses
you just have to find the right one so i
would like photoshop my photos
um and not morphing myself or changing
anything about myself
but changing my background um and
changing like where i was and making
these cool collages
and then young kids in la other kids
like other queer latino kids in la would
be like
you're that curly kid with like the
weird collages on my face and i would be
like oh my god
i mean i remember staying up all night
on the internet just figuring out the
coding
to have the music play on my profile
myspace
i guess was the birth of tinder
facebook instagram all in one and
actually
uh the birth of like spotify i use
myspace for music
i use myspace to show my bullies that i
have friends i
i put like really dark eyeliner all
around my eye and like took a photo
like this like i was your typical and
then of course there's
the notorious top eight if you weren't
in someone's top friends like you had
beef
because it was just like are we really
friends like i'm confused
the creme de la creme
of your friend group essentially i was
having a
fit anytime i wasn't on someone's top
friends i would call them up like
so i'm i don't understand we're best
friends in their life so like why am i
not one of your top friends i don't
understand actually my feelings were
hurt honestly like if i didn't see
myself
in a top three of one of my friends
the friendship was over like why why are
we even friends why are you being
talking
why would you even put that out for the
world to see that we're not even that
close to friends
this is going to shock everyone but i
did not use myspace i
thought i was above my space because
at the time i had facebook in 2008
it felt like everyone had an iphone
except for me i never owned an iphone i
never bought into the hype
i wanted one so badly and everybody
wanted to be a touchscreen ho i mean
the blackberry was slowly dying out and
she was a moment in history i was like a
sidekick kid it was like
i was one of those kids but i pushed
mine up too many times and the screen
came off
so i would just have two parts of a
phone and it would still
ring and buzz when i had text listen
when the iphone came out i think i had a
razor
a pink razer phone in 2008 that was when
the flip phone was dying out but guess
who had it
this guy and guess who was getting no
love because of it
this guy i remember not knowing how to
use the is the iphone
even when they took the button away from
my iphone i was like how do i use this
thing now
i thought iphones were gonna be like a
fad i thought they would disappear
um and look at us in 2020. until this
day
i miss the sidekick i think psychics
needs to make a comeback i think
sidekicks are like
i don't know what it is but i'm a
psychic kid for life forever
love story by taylor swift i remember
crying to that song i mean i don't know
how many breakups i've
had but i know i had one in eighth grade
i know i had one when i was
13 and i remember being in my bed
writing in my diary like
romeo take me i was caught up in the
fairy tale romance that's peak taylor
swift hair
i remember taylor swift's hair kind of
like
defied logic because it was so
curly and the bangs were so straight i
mean she has great hair now but
tea taylor swifter was like the long
curls
she was gorgeous like i was like she's
just a walking barbie doll with a guitar
so like how could you not like her she
was just so young and dreamy eyed
and just wanted to be cool and have a
bae and just live her best life
obama versus mccain it was a big race it
was
someone who was black like me running
for president oh my god
2008 oh when politics made sense
i knew that the candidate was black and
i said
that's it that's my president i mean i
followed the race
for obama's sake i got to see him speak
it was amazing
there was so much exciting and hope he
was like
fresh he was new i've never looked at a
president and been like
okay we all were just so excited like
here he was this beautiful man obama
who just not only was he like super
charming but he was smart and that voice
like and then finally somebody who looks
like as a poc person like somebody who
looks like
us and our friends and the people that
we surround ourselves with
i remember when obama won the election
and me and my sister ran outside in the
middle of the night and screamed
yes and we screamed at the top of our
lungs i'm drowning
in a bog right now and i'm like my hands
reaching up and i'm just trying to reach
to 2008
and remember what that felt like what
would it feel like
to be to be excited about obama i think
that seeing obama
was really important for a lot of
different communities because it
suddenly made it
seem like oh maybe we can
maybe you can be the president of the
united states maybe you can work your
way up to something like this 2008
was the greatest year of all if you
don't think about the recession
2008 was the best year ever because
barack obama
i would totally live 2008 again 2008 was
an exhausting year but a hopeful year
compared to today 2008 made sense
i don't know if i'd live 2008 again it
was fine it had its time
i've moved on
[Music]
[Music]
you